it will reduce the emissions it'll
reduce your bills and this winter so
many Europeans saw sky-high energy bills
the links are really clear
we know that buildings consume a lot of
energy about 40 percent of the energy in
Europe is consumed within buildings and
because of this they also are
responsible for a huge amount of our
greenhouse gas emissions about 36 so
over one third of our greenhouse gas
emissions in Europe are directly or
indirectly coming from buildings so if
we can reduce the emissions from
buildings we're well on our way to
tackling our climate goals and a lot of
people don't know this they think oh
um agriculture transport but actually
buildings and the construction of
buildings users and a lot of energy and
creates a lot of emissions the good news
about all of this is we can do something
about it we can insulate our homes we
can put PV panels photovoltaic panels on
the roofs we can go for new technologies
like heat pumps if we do all of this we
save money and we save the planet
[Music]
this is about taking the buildings that
we're in that we live in that we work in
and improving their energy performance
they consume massive amounts of gas of
oil of electricity and sometimes it's as
easy as just insulation you know the way
estate agents talk about location
location for buildings insulation
insulation insulation but it's not just
insulation we also need new technologies
and if we do this if we upgrade our
buildings if we have a renovation wave
it absolutely saves money of course it's
not cheap it takes real money to do this
but an investment in renovation it has a
payback time it will reduce the
emissions it'll reduce your bills and
this winter so many Europeans saw
sky-high energy bills and we want to
help people move away from that there's
money available from Europe there's
money available from from various
European Union instruments and we think
we can do this and make a real
difference in improving the quality of
people's lives
foreign